hey david do you think mitch mcconnell
and republicans will be punished for
openly obstructing everything joe biden
does as mitch mcconnell has promised to
do
i wish i could tell you yes
the truth is mitch mcconnell might be
rewarded for obstructing everything that
joe biden tries to do there have been no
political consequences for mitch
mcconnell and the republicans of 2016
for blocking
the merrick garland supreme court
nomination made by barack obama and not
only that
many republicans absolutely freaking
love it so um we mean listen the framing
of the question is correct in that
mitch mcconnell has said he's not going
to compromise mitch mcconnell has said
he's not
republicans aren't going to vote for
anything that joe biden wants to do we
saw it with covet stimulus democrats had
to go it completely alone
it looks like it's going to be that way
with infrastructure these republicans
want nothing to do with the covet the
the jobs bill and on and on and on
now there's a couple of different ways
that it could go
one is
these things are popular covid stimulus
was popular infrastructure is popular
if republican voters see that hey we got
this stuff and we like this stuff but
not a single republican voted for it
they may say let's punish these
republicans in the fall
because if it were up to them we would
have gotten nothing at the same time
others would say hey you know what
what i still got the stuff and i don't
even have to vote for democrats so i'll
just keep voting for republicans that's
actually a rationalization we may see
among many of these republican voters i
think the biggest risk to mitch
mcconnell and republicans in their
obstructionism
is that a couple of republican senators
could be mitt romney could be you know
the same people that perennially
disappoint us lisa murkowski susan
collins if a couple of them say
these are
simple
uh needed things that joe biden wants to
do
i'm going to join the democrats
assuming democrats have all 50 of theirs
including joe manchin and kirsten cinema
and get a couple republicans
that could start to hurt mitch mcconnell
where you start seeing republicans
abandoning mitch
and saying now a lot of this stuff just
makes sense to do we need to do the
infrastructure i like the jobs bill etc
that's the biggest risk but republicans
if they remain unified
can withhold
any appearance of bipartisanship
in order to try to harm joe biden and
democrats and it could actually work
there's this you know
bipartisanship in a vacuum polls well
with voters
and so while my view of bipartisanship
is the president should do things that
the american people want if seventy
percent of americans want covet relief
it doesn't really matter
if you don't have enough senate votes
you should do covet relief
that definition of bipartisanship is
very favorable to joe biden the counter
is that there are some americans and
again i i think that
people just working jobs and feeding
their families they don't care about
this stuff but there are people who do
believe
that bipartisanship means you've got to
have some republicans voting for what
you're doing and if republicans can
remain unified
there might be enough of those people in
the republican party who would say joe
biden did it but he didn't do it the
right way with covet cash it's not a
factor i've not heard anyone say i got
my 1400 bucks but i don't want it
because you know mitch mcconnell didn't
vote for it come on guys give me a break
but with some of these other bills that
could become a factor so we're going to
see
the question of whether mitch mcconnell
will be punished for the open
obstruction is a good one
the question of whether mitch mcconnell
will be rewarded for the open
obstruction is just as good of a
question